It's safe to say that Star Wars is likely
the most popular film series of all time.
Not only have the official chapters and growing
number of offshoots brought in billions of
dollars, they've captivated hundreds of millions
the world over with classic stories of good
triumphing over evil.
But it takes a lot of money, time, and effort
to put a Star Wars movie together, which means
once in awhile someone's going to blow a take.
For example ...
Super blooper
Sci-fi films naturally include dialogue with
a lot of technical words, alien planets and
races, unusual character names, and assorted
other jargon.
Actors have to work hard to memorize all that
stuff, or at least be able to read it off
cue cards properly.
But it's a fairly simple word that ended up
throwing off Mark Hamill while filming a scene
inside an X-Wing …
"Now let's get some distance before that thing
goes blah blah."
goes supernova.
How do you pronounce supernova?
What's the inflection?
SUPERnova or superNOVA?."
Man vs. Sword: Round 1
It would seem that the proper handling of
a lightsaber is not really among actor Liam
Neeson's, well,
"...particular set of skills"
Anyway, while portraying Qui-Gon Jinn in The
Phantom Menace, Neeson tried to smoothly unsheathe
Star Wars' trademark weapon, but as this take
proves, he wasn't quite a real-life Jedi master...
Let's see that again — smooth!
Tongue-tied Tarkin
Bloopers can add a fascinating dimension to
extremely familiar movie scenes.
Take, for example, this well-known moment
from A New Hope, in which Princess Leia begs
and pleads with the stone-hearted Governor
Tarkin not to blow up her adopted home planet.
Actor Peter Cushing reels around to chastise
her, but gets tongue-tied …
"No!
Alderaan is peaceful, we have no weapons.
You can't!"
"You would prefer another target, a military
target?
Then name the ... blah!
Name it, now!
Before I go home."
Man vs. Sword: Round 2
At some point in the last 40 years, thousands
of kids have staged an epic, imaginary lightsaber
battle in their bedroom.
In this blooper, Hayden Christensen looks
just like a Star Wars-loving little boy — up
to the moment he loses his balance and feels
the Force…of gravity ...
"You okay?"
"Cut!"
Stuck stormtroopers
Blindly serving the evil Darth Vader, stormtroopers
are intimidating, cutthroat, and unemotional
agents of death and destruction.
What could possibly stop their march of doom?
A hole too small to fit through, apparently,
as seen in this blooper from A New Hope ...
Droid down
From the first Star Wars film until his death
in 2016, actor Kenny Baker operated R2-D2
from the inside.
It's easy to forget that R2 is actually a
relatively clunky costume and not actually
an advanced droid.
This means it can tip over, or the controls
can suddenly go out, as they did in these
bloopers from The Phantom Menace …
Let it go
Saying the right words, moving your body around
the right way, and interacting with other
actors all at the same time — and in the
correct order — can be a lot to remember,
and if an actor screws up just one of those
little things, it ruins the take.
In this scene from Attack of the Clones, Hayden
Christensen knew he was supposed to let go
of Natalie Portman's arm — he just did it
way too early ...
"Where are you going?"
"To find Obi-Wan."
"No, you're not."
"Let go of me."
Obi-Whine Kenobi
After being offered the role of Obi-Wan Kenobi,
but before taking the part, Alec Guinness
called it "fairy-tale rubbish."
He later wrote in a letter during filming
that he didn't enjoy making the movie in part
due to what he called "rubbish dialogue."
That resentment from the legendary English
actor is on display in this blooper from the
set of A New Hope, after he's upstaged by
one of Chewbacca's hairy arms ...
"Here's where the fun begins."
"Well …"
Remember lines he cannot
Even the most vocal The Phantom Menace detractor
— of which there are many — has to admit
that a highlight from the first, long-awaited
Star Wars prequel was the return of Yoda.
Frank Oz returned to provide the Jedi Master's
grammatically wonky voice, and even though
Oz wasn't physically on camera at all, he
still seemed to get nervous on set ...
"Always two there are: no more, no less.
Now I forgot my line!"
"Can I cut, George?"
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!